today I'm going to be reviewing the
trailer for Jurassic world if you guys
are familiar with the show I know that
maybe it doesn't look the same but
that's cuz I'm in the process of moving
and moving requires you to pack all your
[ __ ] up but then you have these things
called fans and fans are like dude where
is the Jurassic world trailer review
hello they don't realize that maybe
maybe I have a personal life but no no
I'm a youtuber so I gotta tend to the
fans and plus it was a good chance for
me to actually get away from helping
with all the packing and unpacking so I
made up this whole excuse like I really
got to film this but Veronica's taking
care of everything she's a good
girlfriend so what I'm trying to say is
I got this half a shadow thing going on
which is it cool because it looks like
I'm conflicted about something and we're
gonna be checking out Jurassic world the
trailer at this further premiered at the
Superbowl people are raving the [ __ ]
about it so let's check it out okay
[Music]
we have traction and ghetto scare the
kids this will give the pit inside but
he's swimming made a new dinosaur me not
a good idea
oh god it's killing for sport
[Music]
holy [ __ ] no it was awesome I don't
really actually go back and revisit a
lot of these trailers on my own time but
I've seen the jurassic world once
several times now so when the trailer
first started out I was like okay we've
seen that before it still looks cool and
creepy but one of the later images we
got was of Chris Pratt and he was like
you know talking to the Raptors me like
yo chill your horses [ __ ]
it's cool to see that a raptor training
thing going on because we've seen three
movies now where ain't chance in hell
you could train a raptor but I'm
interested to see how you can actually
tame one you know it's weird there was
Jurassic Park and then there was the
lost world and Jurassic Park 3 yet none
of those seemed like they were at all in
tune with the first Jurassic Park Steven
Spielberg directed part 2 yet it didn't
really feel like Jurassic Park which is
OK in some ways because you don't want
to feel exactly the same but this one
feels like Jurassic Park again it seems
like it's gonna play out similar to the
first one where they're introducing you
to this world it's beautiful it's
awesome you kind of wish this theme park
was real and then shit's about to go
down the action sequences seem directed
with a lot of tension and fear it's not
like crazy Hollywood overblown Bonanza
crap in a way it's being captured it's
it's filled with a lot of fears yeah I
like what they're doing with the new
dinosaur the hybrid because I hope that
they kind of do that Godzilla thing
about it where you don't get a super
clear image of this dinosaur that often
you kind of look out for images of them
but from the few glimpses we get of this
new dinosaur whole [ __ ] is [ __ ] scary
dude Chris Pratt's hiding underneath
that car and then he's the teeth and you
there's blood on it
it's [ __ ] horrifying [ __ ] like this
dinosaur is something that the real
working like crazy to take down there's
that one shot in the helicopter with the
machine gun or whatever that's called
Gatling gun I don't know enough where
they're shooting after the dinosaur
that's just a it's just a really cool
shot but B it really does give you a
good example of how intense this [ __ ] is
because I don't recall ever seen that
happened in the first three and I'm kind
of wondering how they are gonna reboot
this franchise because lost world in
Jurassic Park 3d took place on Islands
not at a park and this one it's taking
place in a parking in with and [ __ ] goes
wrong all over again never learned their
lesson now one scene where like you guys
probably know the exact dinosaur but the
pterodactyl I'm gonna call it comes up
and swoops that lady out of the crowd
holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
I remember in part three there was
something like that but it just came
across super cheesy and this one that
looked really scaredy I'm kind of hoping
that this trailer is not showing us the
ABC step of this cuz it looks like Park
opens is beautiful then everything
starts falling apart then finale when
Chris Pratt is like yo we got to use all
these things at them including my
dinosaurs my dinosaur gang I just don't
like predicting things like that right
off the trailer that's how the trailer
is kind of communicating to me ass but
I'm hoping it doesn't just play out that
simple and but if it does I'm hoping the
execution is still really unique then
when those two kids are in the car at
the end and then the [ __ ] clock comes
through you know it seems like it's
paying tribute to the first Jurassic
Park with the brother and sister who
were trapped in the car I like that I
like that whole like omage thing they
got going on anyway guys if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects where we have better
equipment and lighting coming up soon
shoutouts will continue once the new set
is up so go to facebook.com slash the
real reject shoutouts where you can earn
yourself shout out by saying something
like right you put B usually
good puppy Ryan's a good puppy to this
puppy and Ryan gets all the pups all
that he has sex with all the puppies
there's another energy when I transfer
we do a puppy isn't that what happens
Russia I turn into a little horn dog
don't I yeah cuz I'm a shapeshifter
like Sam from True Blood